європейська Солідарність однозначно буде
підтримувати всі два законопроекти які
передбачають зняття оподаткування на
запчастини для виробництва Дронів але
давайте будемо чесні волонтери про це
говорили з перших днів вторгнення і
давайте будемо чесні це треба було
приймати кілька місяців тому коли ми
знімали оподаткування безпосередньо з
Дронів але одна спеціальна структура в
Україні рік блокувала взагалі питання
ввезення Дронів а якась падлюка
перепрошує на парламентському слові ще й
втрапила просити польських митників
зупинити віз Дронів тому що в Україні
вони бачите подвійного призначення коли
ми цю людину питалися А як же ж так це ж
кожен Дрон - це ціна врятованих життів
нам відмовчується і ця людина досить
пірить ця структура не понесли
відповідальності але давайте будемо щирі
а те саме відбувалося із ракетної
програмою а те саме відбувалося І
відбувається
катерами з 19-го року зупинені всі ці
були програми проти розробників
броньованих катерів було купа
кримінальних справ репресії ув'язнення а
в результаті все підходить І все треба і
На даному етапі нам з вами нарешті треба
почати думати стратегічно нам треба
системно відновлювати оборонну
промисловість України для кожної воюючої
держави Оборонна промисловість - це
основа не тільки розвитку Але виживання
економіки створення робочих місць і
можливості забезпечувати самих себе тими
снарями різними спецтехнікою яка дасть
можливість боронитися проти Московської
агресії Ну але нам треба було півтора
роки щоби подумати про те що дрони
будуть рятувати життя і треба ввозити
комплектуючи але так само і попросила
щоб комітети із закордонних справ і
євроінтеграції і спеціальні структури
подумали над тим чому До сих пір р
волонтери на кордоні мають проблему із